hi everyone welcome to this series of
videos for the topic of vectors this
chapter is important for mathematics and
it also forms the basis for the next
chapter that is three-dimensional
geometric there will be series of videos
for this topic in this first video I
will just like to talk about very basic
stuff and I will try to define vectors I
believe that there is a lot of confusion
among students about even basic things
of definition of vectors like position
vector line vector unit vector and
magnitude I think if you can really
focus on this video and really try to
understand the difference between
position vector and line vector that
will vary value that will clarify a lot
of things for you so let me start by
defining what a position vector is so
first before I am going into position
vector let me just briefly summarize
vectors for you in case you are not
familiar I believe you have already
learned about vectors in capitals for
physics like kinematics and forces and
all that you should know that vectors
are quantities where which has which
have both magnitude as direction and
they are very very important for in
general for scientific development so
let just me start let me start by
defining water position vectors so a
position vector
is a vector connecting
origin to a point okay and as a name
suggest basically this position vector
is about the position of one point and I
think this is where a lot of students
get confused even the most basic
definition of position vector so let us
say we have so a good thing about
vectors is that it will always be in
three dimensions and that will be really
helpful for you in the next chapter of
three-dimensional geometry so that is
why it is important for you to
understand position vectors and things
things like line vector unit vector so
let us just initially focus on position
vectors so what what are the definition
a position vector is a vector connecting
origin to a point so let us say we have
a point P with coordinates px py and P
is Z and position vector is let us call
this as x axis y axis and z axis
position vector is a vector connecting
origin which is o to the point P and
pointing in direction of P this
direction pointing is very important
because if it is in the opposite
direction then the vector will not will
not will be something else so whenever
we write a vector o P vector this is
called au p vector the first factor is
from where the arrow line connects to
the second point and P the second the
second alphabet which is P in this case
o P vector is the significance signify
the direction of the vector for instance
what I am trying to say is that if you
have au p vector o P vector then the
vector will start from O and end at P
okay and in this case whoopi vector
actually means P X I cap I hope you are
familiar with I cap I cap means the
direction in the x axis plus p YJ cap
plus PZ k cap okay so x axis y axis and
z axis
okay another point that you can probably
you might want to know is that magnitude
of Opie rector is square root of P X
square plus py square plus PZ square
okay so let us just take a very quick
example for this if we have a point a
let us say we have a point a point a
with coordinates 3 comma 2 comma 1
[Music]
what is position vector
and its magnitude
okay and the answer is very you can very
quickly write the answer
so we will write Oh a vector for a
vector is three i cap plus 2j cap plus k
cap and over a vector magnitude is
square root of 3 square plus 2 square
plus 1 is square root of 14 okay so just
to give you a very quick example that
position vector is always and always for
a point position vector is always for a
point okay please do not forget this
very very basic definition of position
vector trust me it will happen it will
sometime happen during the chapter of
vectors that will get confused if you do
not I if you forget this point so please
try to remember that position vector is
always and always for a point okay now
let us try to move to a new type of
vector which is called the line vector
the position vector is for a point and
line vector is for a line so as simple
as that so if you have a line let us
take connecting two points a and B so if
I write small a vector here a small B
vector here so what does this mean a
vector is for point a and small B vector
is for point B whenever you see
something like this in brackets
it just means because it is for a point
it refers to the position vector in
other words a vector is nothing but a
vector and B vector is nothing but OB
vector and what are over a truss and OB
vectors they are Oh P vector like
position vectors of point a and B so
even this basic thing people get really
confused so whenever you see points a
point a and something written in the
bracket of that that always means it is
a position vector okay so what does line
vector mean so line letter means
connecting two points and if you have
something like a B vector
a B letter again starting from a and
ending at B so direction arrow goes from
A to B then this vector is defined as B
vector minus a vector or in other words
a b vector is OB vector minus four
vector okay so let us try to take one
example and quickly hopefully we'll be
able to understand what I am trying to
say what is the vector
joining sine theta I cap plus cos theta
J cap and
zero comma zero comma one okay
what is its magnitude
so let us try to find the answer for
this very quickly so we have been given
I mean it might be a little confusing of
how it has been written here so sine
theta I cap plus cos beta J cap is
basically a point for which you have
been given a position vector so joining
this and this so we will assume that a
vector is sine theta I cap plus cos
theta J cap and theta can be any
parameter basically theta is an angle
and a parameter a it has not been given
to us what is this value of theta so it
is fine but we can still calculate the
answer and B vector is nothing but K cap
right so what will be B vector minus a
vector will be K cap minus sine theta I
cap minus cos theta J cap and magnitude
of any vector would be similar to right
like we define Oh P vector magnitude
basically squaring all the components so
minus sine theta whole square plus minus
cos theta whole square plus 1 whole
square and sine square theta plus cos
square theta is 1 so a B vector
magnitude is root 2 okay so in this part
I just wanted to emphasize that line
vector is for a line and position vector
is for a point now there are also some
vectors which people get always confused
about so here both the vectors are fixed
because it always started from a and
going and it went to B and this time
from oh and when to P however you should
realize that sometimes vectors are also
freely used in terms of that the vectors
are not fixed it the only fix the
magnitude and direction but they do not
fix the position for instance if I have
a vector if I define a vector let me
create another space say and just call
that as a free vector
okay if I have been given a vector a and
I have been told that it is ICAP plus j
k plus k cap and i have not been given
anything information any other
information about this so what would
this vector represent this vector
represents a lot of things for instance
it can represent a point such that Oh a
vector let us say this is the point 1
comma 1 comma 1 then Oh a vector could
be I cap plus ZK plus k cap similarly
this can also represent a line vector
which means that it can the B vector
minus a vector for instance it can join
two points and can the difference can
come out as I can as a kappa skype k cap
okay however free vector by free letter
i means that i just know the direction
and magnitude but it is free to rotate
in this 3d space for instance let us say
there is this vector which i am holding
here if there is if this vector it can
freely rotate it is not changing its
direction it is not changing its
magnitude so that is a free vector so if
you have not been specified a position
specific position from where it starts
from origin and hinge at a position or
it joins two points it can also be a
free vector and I wanted want to
emphasize this because you will see
later in this chapter that many many
times it happens that people really get
confused about free vectors that they
are not able to understand it similarly
they get confused between oh what is the
vector connecting two line two points
and they get confused whenever C
notation with a vector in the brackets
or small e vector in the brackets so
this will summarize whenever is whenever
you see a point it always means a
position vector whenever you see a point
it always means a position vector
whenever you see a vector joining two
points it means a line vector which can
be which can be calibrated like this and
whenever you see something just written
like this and not specify whether it is
a point or whether it is a line vector
then it means it is a free vector which
only has a fixed magnitude and direction
and can move freely around the space
okay now till now I have always only
talked about the magnitude of the vector
here abv
they're open letter that you can just
take the x-component square Y component
square and Z component square and take a
square root of that however there is
something also very important for a
vector and that is its direction so let
me start by defining unit vector so
whenever I write a vector a which is for
instance written here I can also write
vector a as magnitude of vector a into
unit vector okay so what what does this
mean this means that a vector has some
magnitude which you can again calculate
by squaring X component Y component Z
component and adding them and taking a
square root and this this a cap is
nothing but the unit vector or something
which I really really preferred to use
the direction of the vector so unit
vector in direction are synonymous many
people get confused about this unit
reparent
Direction are synonymous so whenever you
have a vector it is a multiplication of
its magnitude into its direction or its
unit vector so for instance if I have to
calculate a unit vector calculate a unit
vector of a vector
Victor II if you want to do that then
you can write a a cap as vector a by mod
of a vector a in this case is I cap plus
J cap plus K cap + mod of a is square
root of 1 square plus 1 square plus 1
square and this means I cap plus J cap
by square root of root square root of 3
ok
in other words I can also write that a
vector is root 3 times I cap plus J cap
plus K cap by square root of root 3
square root of 3 and this is the
direction which is a unit vector and
this is the value ok so if if you want
to calculate the let us say another let
us just write another question what is
the direction of x-axis
x-axis
so if you have a direction of x-axis
direction means a unit vector so in that
case a cap would be Direction is AB
something with the magnitude of one and
we know the direction of x axis is I cap
and it also has a magnitude of one so it
is just I cap I cap is nothing but a
direction so whenever I write something
like PX i cap plus py z k+ p XP z k cap
it means that i have moved
PX in the x direction right i cap and
then i have added something with and I
have moved P by in the z direction and
then I have moved pk in the PZ in the K
direction so that is how you define
direction by unit vectors so till now in
this video we just covered very basic
stuff position vector refers to a point
line vector say first joining two points
free letter F refers to a vector which
is not neither a point nor a line there
is something that can move freely around
the space has a fixed magnitude in a
fixed direction and at last unit vector
means just the direction where to divide
the vector by its magnitude and we did a
very quick calculation to see that so I
hope this was clear just take some time
and digest these things and the next
video we will talk about things like
addition of vectors and section formula
thank you